Here's the answer. We can define sum3.
We're going to use the procedure definition syntax.
So we have the def, followed by the name sum3, and now we need to find our parameters.
Since there are 3 inputs, we need 3 names.
We can make up the names whatever we want.
I'm just going to use a, b, and c.
Using letters like a, b, and c for inputs is usually not a good idea.
They don't tell us a lot about what they're supposed to mean.
In this case, since the inputs are just 3 numbers, and they don't mean anything special,
we don't have any different meaning for the 3 numbers.
Using a, b, and c is sort of sensible.
But for most procedures, we want to use names that gives us a good idea
of what the inputs are supposed to mean.
Now we have our 3 inputs.
We can produce the output right away just by adding those 3 numbers.